you guys played this joke on me uh you
when your pregnancy test came in
and you run it on your instagram your
pregnancy test came in
positive instead of telling me that you
were having your second child what did
you
what did you do i was pregnant
i found out i was pregnant i already
told my husband i told my brother
and then i thought it would be really
funny to give my brother
my positive pregnancy test and pretend
like he's the one that got a girl
pregnant and the reason why this is
funny is because
he doesn't have a wife he doesn't even
have a girlfriend
he has no one
he should be getting pregnant right now
or at least not that we know of
and so he took the positive pregnancy
test
gathered us all around and then told my
parents
that he got a girl pregnant and we just
watched your reactions
and mom's reaction was the funniest but
it was
hilarious so and to that that's how i
talk
for just a second now she's talking
about uh that's alex mandel my son
her brother who is single and and
maybe we can make it a mission uh to
ready to mingle girls he's single and
ready to mingle and he knows
all these animal facts he has a catch
he is a catch and he does so many
different things he's got so much talent
too
right he's a licensed a lot of talent
he's a bartender he's an ordained
minister didn't he marry you
yes he's also a massage therapist he's a
massage therapist
he goes and gets his licenses for
everything and he says mostly because he
doesn't have interest in these things
but they're uh that he can park
in different places ordained minister on
the church's business can park
a jew on the church's business can park
anywhere he wants
and as a massage therapist he puts that
in front of the gym
as if he's working there and that's
where he parks and a bartender any club
he likes they think he's the bartender
because he's got a bartending pass
i don't even know what that is but he
doesn't have a
bartending pass i don't know what he has
but he doesn't have a girlfriend right
now we're gonna we should try to get him
one that could be our mission
really that we should we should try i
mean
get him i've been trying for a long time
i have been trying to set him up on
dates
i'm finding him i've you're calling him
yeah it doesn't matter are you putting
him on the spot
maybe we'll see if he answers go ahead
no keep talking oh there he is
alex alex yeah yeah you're on the
podcast
with me and jackie okay
jackie was just saying that you were
single
and ready to mingle uh yes
jackie you want it can you hear him yeah
can he hear me
yeah so what is it that you're looking
for in a significant others that we can
help because we
we believe we have many listeners that
might be interested
i'm looking for someone that is
interested
so he sets the bar he sets the bar
so [ __ ] high he really does i'm so
proud of him
there's so many that i go for and
they're just not interested that i think
that
my type is someone who's interested wow
wow so if you're interested
you're his type yep i mean maybe we can
have a place on the website where people
can write in
and submit um inquiries about
alex maybe we could find myself as
sister-in-law
alex that'd be nice if you had to write
a like right now
uh like a you know when you have those
dating apps which
i got the dating apps i don't know if
you know this jackie he got mad at mom
two weeks ago tell tell tell
jackie what happened well i started
getting emails
from saying you got new matches from all
different
online dating sites and i didn't know
where they were coming from and then i
called and
mom was like i was just you know just
putting your picture up there you look
so cute with harvey you and your dog
and uh i was seeing if maybe you can
meet someone nice
she set up the account on four different
how many different accounts
dad you're gonna have to ask him because
i don't think he can hear me oh how many
different accounts did she put you on
i i would say about four or five did you
meet it did you meet up with anybody
no because i didn't mom didn't give me
the login details and she didn't
remember it after she made it so i just
got emails that there were matches but
uh i wasn't able to see them it was just
uh
it's like a blind dating site he got
girls that were interested but he
couldn't do anything about it so he got
girls
that's we'll make sure that we'll take
it right to fruition
what is it if you have to fill out one
of those dating app things what do they
call it
you put down like even on a personal ad
what would you say about
yourself describe yourself so the the
interested
parties out there can
how what do you mean i feel like how
would you describe me
you like taking long walks on the beach
well long walks on short beaches right
well when you walk
when you take long walks on the beach a
lot of people walk along the beach you
always walk toward the water and that's
why they're short walks
yeah no it's long walks on short beaches
okay long walks on short beaches go
ahead write this down ladies he's cuddly
he's cuddly you don't want to hear that
from your sister
your sister said you're cuddly i'm
cuddly
well with with my dog
but is there room for a third to come in
he actually doesn't like when i if i
even
touch a lady friend
you want to elaborate yeah like if i
have a friend over who's who happens to
be a lady friend
even if i hugged her he's really angry
he won't allow it